and I think it's you know it's a  disgrace you have a loser like guys a  stone-cold loser has been all his life  Adam Schiff and then you have Nancy  Pelosi who agreed with what he said  which puts her into real jeopardy agreed  on a certain show Stephanopoulos and  frankly it's a bad thing for the country  I'm over here with NATO we're meeting  with in this case Italy but we're  meeting with great countries very  important countries we're doing a good  job and they scheduled that same thing  happened a number of months ago when  they put the United Nations the Unga  they put the United Nations situation  they had a hearing with somebody on the  same day and now they do it with data  these people you almost question whether  or not they love our country and that's  a very very serious thing  you